[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from bone Appetit HQ and lower Manhattan
where I'm joined by Test Kitchen manager
Brad Leone you know Brad from bone
Appetit its webseries it's alive where
week over week he does the impossible
makes fermented foods sexy but listen
we're not here for kimchi or bean paste
we're here to revive a first we feast
classic rat are you ready to nacho
reckon so Sean hope you uh hope you
brought your a-game
Hey hi buddy Ida hi all right Brad
before we begin before we roll our
sleeves up what's the perfect plate of
nachos for you for me it's not a nice
you know a crisp chip preferably a
yellow corn not flavored and then just I
like a double layer you know nothing
crazy it's not a garbage can you know
it's not just throw whatever you got
it's a well calculated decision balance
yeah balance balance baby but at the end
of the day you know if you mess up it's
still it's not gonna taste bad i Brad
enough chitchat what are you gonna be
making today
all right so for me I mean it starts
we're gonna use the same chip you know
that's kind of be that's gonna be the
control we're gonna balance out the
playing field you know I don't want you
showing up with your Doritos or whatever
so I did a braised of pork shoulder and
smoked ham hocks in a little bit of
water wine and some toasted chilies that
I pureed and with the ham hocks the meat
just kind of shreds apart same with the
shoulders little black olives and then
for the cheese I got yellow cheddar
pepper jack and Monterey Jack
we'll get that we'll do a two layer a
melt and then when we pull it out of the
oven that's when I'll garnish there's
some secret weapons on guys the car ride
in I had a false sense of security I
think like that because when you just
hit that down like now my mouth is
watering thinking and my boot is like
that right I hope I brought enough
firepower to eat kitchen
[Music]
before I go putting on the next layer of
chips I kept out a little ingredient a
little well curveball Oh y'all so here I
got in this nice little pot I got so
this is some pinto pinto beans that i
just i heated up with a little wine a
little bit of water and kind of a bunch
of pork fat all right cool
so now I'm just gonna repeat that well
I'm pretty pretty excited to see what
you got you up your sleeve over there
showing you got some I thought I brought
the wild cards this guy on this
particular nacho what I'm doing is a
little roll wink to the three one two
little Windy City love here for the
nachos we're gonna go with a queso sauce
Lincoln at the three one two with the
jardin era and then on top of that the
big a SUP my sleeve is that I'm going
with some Italian beef another little
nod at Chicago gonna put some grated
cheese on top and then finally we're
gonna run it through the garden put some
wheels on it and then I'm gonna present
it and just pray to the nacho gods yeah
we all do now that you've heard what I'm
gonna make little classic Shawn move I'm
gonna lean on the competition to help me
across the finish line so let's start
with the case let's start with the room
we're kind of making a béchamel sauce
this is what are the the mother sauces
as they call it if you're not familiar
with the roux
so you're melting your butter you're
getting that real nice and then you're
gonna add your flour
we're whisk and you're gonna let that
get real toasty and now we're just gonna
fold in some of the cheese and get that
kind of nice and melty in there and then
well I'll call it cheese sauce is that
all it goes into the cheese sauce no
this is going in to the cheese sauce
what do you think an absolute I think
that's the best idea I've heard all day
and then how you feel about chopping
that up I don't know what your knife
skills are I mean I get I got this nice
old workers that's very very serious I'm
happy to do it let me let me let me give
it a go but yeah yeah yeah see I just
like to give it a little rough chop you
know I think this is gonna be great in
the cheese sauce it's just not me
excited about the cheese's that hasn't
happened
check this out you ever seen a guy play
as nachos like just what I thought I
knew you all right then on top of that
we're going beef the queso looks ready
sure does I think it's just we rain we
rained the queso down on this now all
this goes in there I'm at that point
where I'm like everything sure let's
just go
yeah all right going down hopefully the
move here is that it seeps into this
deep bedrock of chip out of the bedrock
and then you just end up in a beautiful
place yes I mean I saw a similar artwork
piece on the on the floor on the subway
terminal this morning too but it was
cute all right we are fresh out of the
oven and you know what that means it's
time to figure out whose nachos reign
supreme to the judge's table
we welcome bone Appetit deputy editor
Andrew Knowlton what do you look for in
a perfect plate of nachos an A+ it's
about the architecture of a nacho and
the good thing about for you yeah
there's no rules when it comes to nachos
clearly clearly I'm seeing some black
olives over here I'm scared shitless of
black olives out of a can so maybe the
scales are tipping even a little bit on
your side right now so I'm clearly so
he's gotta win me over I love it I love
it so we'll start here I got a little
refried well pinto beans that I cooked
in a little white wine and a decent
amount of rendered pork fat and we got
our ham hocks and the pork shoulder in
there and then we'll do a little avocado
some pickled red onions and this is a
little fermented lacto-fermented sweet
and hot peppers that I just ringed up
next we'll finish with a little bit I
got a little cotija cheese I can't stand
that cheese oh that's good I'm glad
you're judging anyway not too much cuz
we got plenty of cheese on there I just
like judging not too much Oh
sauce on the side sour cream little
dollop and we'll do a little cilantro
just to finish all right sure why don't
you walk us through your super sandwich
over there
all right so what I did is a little knot
a little wink at Chicago there's a
little garden era in with the queso
situation and then what we've done is
we've put some Italian beef as a layer
and now just a little just a little
action dragging it through the gardens
is there broccoli in there
there's no broccoli in this it kind of
looks like a broccoli I know it I know I
know you had me and now the relish is
like the relish is your black olive I
feel like the the two of us we've just
blown out our hands raised like right as
we approach the finish line I'm gonna be
25 miles no problem I'm gonna have to be
like my six-year-old daughter and like
ask you guys to pick through the olives
and the in the relish just to get me to
eat it and then just a little hot one
sauce like a little drizzle action oh
yeah
what raft about what flavors really good
you know what I like the relish more
than I thought I would
Cindy you painted yourself into a corner
that I did a time and then I serve up
that plate now we're rethinking some
things but that's where the compliments
I think in your bagging about nachos
been shitty nachos are good nachos
exactly you know all right so we got the
ham hocks
yeah ham hock pork shoulder really good
acidity going on with all these peppers
and the onions that's nice I'm gonna do
this in three parts cuz I love this is
the way I do them as you eat with your
eyes right first yes then I think Brad
squarely one one that you checked that
box I mean it takes a man hand up I
agree I'm gonna go with creativity I'm
gonna give it to you because I've never
had nachos like this at Chicago style
relish who would have thought I might
have to bring that into my nacho making
skills now fair game so then it comes
down to taste well considering that that
layering and like I said when I come
back at 2:00 in the morning and I know I
have to get up in the morning and wake
up my kids but I'm still gonna [ __ ]
make nachos which nachos what I'd rather
eat yeah it's tough I hate to do this
because we work together yeah but I'm
gonna have to give oh no no no no I
think I'm gonna have to give it to Brad
I think the only one I know this seems
like home cooking no but this is just
too far removed that this is just too
far out of my head space to to consider
these nachos I hope I brought enough
firepower kitchen these this is this is
a casserole the queso looks ready I
think it's just we rain we rained the
queso down on this now all this goes
they respect your creativity but I'm
gonna give it to you Thank You bud yeah
that was very Simon Cowell you know they
set you up like you're gonna move on oh
you're getting a golden ticket and then
just BAM I had the door slammed in on me
last second the bitter taste of defeat
it's something I've felt many times
taste like that but you know what it's
okay cuz all is fair and love and nachos
it's alive on YouTube Bon Appetit make
sure you subscribe your nachos don't let
anyone tell you you can't make them the
way that you want it's a blank canvas do
it your way I love you Sean Evans the
first we feast you already know
[Music]